much they're perfect it's been a second
you guys know hi my name is Chris help
you don't know know you know your life
is different now yeah I'm doing a
Grammys fashion review it's been a
second since I've done one of these and
I feel like I want to do one of these
and thus I am doing one of these can you
believe it let's stop the small talk and
let's get into the fashions a [ __ ] as
always for those of you that might have
forgot or those of you that might be new
I don't know anything about anything
specially not music if we do the math on
that never been good at fractions but I
do know that I will know a fraction of
the people that I'm about to look at is
this too bright on my face
oh wow oh look it says I have not looked
at any of these yet I won't know how to
pronounce names I won't know if anyone
is a person that does the thing I know
that they were photographed at this
thing and we're gonna say things about
those things also I'll definitely not
get to everybody that you might want me
to talk about expectations like an
unwinnable limbo contests that bar is
way down here is he Teigen oh you look
like one of the Fanta girls got a dress
made on a two-day challenge on Project
Runway it's like one of those like
Victorian collars but that Victorian
collar like took some mushrooms cute
ariana grande wow this is a grande dress
you look like a really sexy chimney like
an elegant smokestack you look smoking
and you stacked I guess like Home Depot
has to restock its shelves because you
took all the tools you took all the tool
in a second you guys cute Gwen Stefani
yeah Wow you look like a girl who's
about to go to homecoming and her
parents on the way out the door like
wait wait wait we have to take a photo
of you but I don't want to stand near
the creaky staircase in front of the
photo of you and your brothers that's
covered in dust from fourth grade just
stick stick come on I'm not letting you
leave until you take a [ __ ] cute yeah
you look like a wedding cake with sex
boots cute billy Eilish I love this this
is like Hugh Hefner meets Ninja Turtle
meets Marilyn Manson meets a lizard
person that's trying not to get the flu
cute Tyler the Creator yes I will carry
this bellhops bags anywhere everywhere I
also think it's very smart when you go
to an event like this to carry your
luggage with you because it is boring
you can just you're ready to get on a
plane you got that TSA pre I'm sure you
probably got clear you probably don't
even have to go through any security at
the airport you just like probably float
to wherever you need to get to cute fka
twigs is this how I say it's hot twig I
mean this outfit says it looks like
there was some like glitch in the time
travel between like the Victorian age
and 2020 and this was the result
it also looks kind of like a Victorian
Snuggie like I feel like you could lay
down to be instantly a comforter cute
lissa oh damn this Hollywood glam I love
Liz Oh cuz you don't know what to expect
and she can pull off literally any era
style trend this is so classy and demure
but also cool and she you look at this
woman you're like your blood is made of
vodka martinis and blue cheese stuffed
olives yeah Bonnie McKee whoo this is
look at the Little Mermaid like got sick
of her marriage and was like I'm gonna
be an entrepreneur and read girl Boston
went to like a female empowerment rally
and just learned how to harness all of
her sexual prowess and magnificent brain
that's what this look says to me yeah
Lana Del Rey I love this I also love
this because I did see a Twitter moment
that said that Lana bought this dress at
the mall and I think that that's
wonderful
guys the mall the mall is back said no I
think there's really an Amazon packets
being delivered in my house at this
current moment cute John Legend wow this
is a magic eye this is like two-face is
a stockbroker half of the time and like
a Braveheart enthusiast the other half
of the time very fun must be slightly
annoying to pee in more really fun to
pee in cute do a leap oh wow I wouldn't
have recognized her without her name
being directly under her photo this
looks like you're doing Gwen Stefani 90s
cosplay debut accidentally gorilla glue
your arms to the side of your body
[Music]
either way cute Shania Twain wow this is
a lot of look you kind of look like
Maria Menounos for a second and also
Fergie Wow
I don't know I don't what a man I feel
like a woman so I like the Grammys
because the Grammys I feel like the
fashion motto is just pile it on it was
like Jennifer Coolidge from Legally
Blonde got stuck in like a dominatrix
mosquito net Jew who's getting malaria
at this awards show uh-uh not Fergie
I mean Shania Twain Heidi Klum is there
thank God Wow
I forgot that I cared about Heidi Klum
being at award shows until now and you
know what my subconscious anxiety is
quelled does that a word
who gives a Heidi Klum's at an award
show all is right in the world this
looks like Tron meets Great Gatsby and
you know what I'm here for it I guess
sexy tinsel robe you know we need all
year round Christmas and Heidi cute
Billy Porter oh my god Wow
I hope not everyone at this show is a
vegetarian because that's one rare
porterhouse oh and yeah I did Google of
porterhouse is a steak it's a steak I
also saw the video of how the fringe on
his hat opens like this
it's like future cowboy church-lady
meets Boogie Nights meets a Clydesdale
meets just like perfection this feels
like if you know the man in the yellow
hat from Curious George really was
curious and did drag one night but it'd
be something like this oh I love it
cute lil nose Wow oh my god this is so
fun holy [ __ ] did I say little NAS I
meant little nas ex
guys I said this colors fantastic
handkerchiefs on the wrists are great
the boots the belts the straps the icing
is quaking right now we're gonna talk
about malls I hope the new season of
Westworld goes more in this direction
cute Diplo I mean compared to Lunas like
what are you even doing this is like the
Mormon version
what I just saw but I mean like cool
Shawn Mendes well you look like you're
gonna try to show me some sleight of
hand this feels like Sherlock Holmes
like went with a shaman and did peyote
for a little bit and got some crystal
healings under his belt and came back
and decided he wanted to solve mysteries
with his energy
Zhu Ben Platt oh this is fun and you
don't look at all uncomfortable I feel
like this is something like a stepmom or
in the 80s I also feel like this is a
look in which I feel like you're gonna
try and show me some sleight of hand but
this time I'm like yeah but you get that
is my cards how did you know it was
diamonds oh you cute my mom's calling
mom mom I have to call you back I'm
judging millionaires Lilly Singh loved
it this color looks beautiful on her she
looks very elegant but fun she's got a
purse full of Skittles staying true to
her brand cuz you know if the apocalypse
happened during the Grammys you don't
need your ID you don't need your credit
card but you do need to eat so she came
prepared
cute Tove lo whoa this is very fun this
is like an award show mullet party on
top business on the bottom this is also
like every horny middle school boys
fantasy of they're like female okay guys
that's it that's my very quick review of
the Grammy's fashions I know I missed a
lot of people and it's mostly because I
don't know who's who and what's what I
also don't know a lot about the Grammys
if you like this video give it a thumbs
up I mean no clue where your favorite
looks at the Grammys in the comments
down below
don't forget to subscribe to this
YouTube channel I'm making videos here
and there isn't that fun to subscribe
yourself one who doesn't give you a
consistent reassurance of content my
YouTube channels like a scratch-off
ticket take a chance on it you might win
big other than that I don't know
Skrillex what Wow is that did you get
queer eyed Wow cute